they've been asking a lot about some
audio Big Finish audios I've been doing
with Tom Baker so they all seem to be
very excited about the thought of
listening to those which is very nice
many of them you know you meet for the
second third fourth fifth times there
they are so loyal these fans they go to
all these things so it's very nice
seeing old faces again that one sees
often and then meeting new ones and
seeing other people from other programs
who you wouldn't normally in and indeed
meeting colleagues from dr. who who
you've never met except on these sorts
of things which as you mentioned the
dedication of the fans they are so
dedicated are they what is it about
Doctor Who you think that really
inspires that impressive dedication it
appeals to such a wide age range it
appeals to such a wide culture range
it's one of those quirky odd programs
that somehow has managed to survive over
time and I think when things survive
that long it has to be for some reason
and I'm not quite sure what the reason
is I think it's that it's metamorphosed
and kept up with the times
both the technologically and story-wise
and everything else and I think that
somehow maybe appeals to people in some
way I don't really know I mean thinking
about your own role in Doctor Who I mean
what was it you enjoyed about being part
of that world it was very very clunky in
my day technologically there were no
computers you know
it's weird to think that one is going
back to an age before the work computers
and so everything was kind of blue
screen backgrounds and very slow and
hard painstaking stuff to make special
effects and some of the things them some
of the spaceships honestly came out of
cornflakes packets with little wires
attached they were really really but I
loved all that I loved I loved learning
about the techniques of filming that
sort of thing which now are completely
obsolete of course but at the time you
know they were interesting it was
intriguing talking to the cameramen and
talking to the special effects people
and learning this stuff and looking back
on it now of course it's all very
strange compared with what you can so
easily do with computers but no 1980 79
80 when I was doing it there were no
computers I had the biggest thrill on
earth a couple of years ago which was to
meet overall conveying a sort of
conference in the Canary Islands Neil
Armstrong and I got to know him a teeny
bit as far as you could over those very
short few days and sat next to him on a
plane flying between islands in the
Canaries and he said to me do you know
that the computer we had for the first
moon landing was the memory on that
computer was 32 K that's a drop in the
ocean of any sort of gameboy machine or
you know any little lost mobile phone
now has trillions more memory than 32 K
you know
and when we were doing Doctor Who we
didn't even have 32k we weren't trying
to land on the moon we were trying to
make it look as if we were landing on
the moon but you know it was a very
bygone time but I think a very
interesting one for that thinking about
the kind of look of the show that's
having your look as well as a character
even how much input did you have into
how you looked on-screen quite a lot the
first story I did was a an unmemorable
worm called The Creature from the pit
and I wore a dress that might have
looked great on certainly would have
looked great on Mary tam who was my
predecessor but looked utterly
ridiculous on me I simply couldn't do
that sort of glamour and I didn't know
at that stage because it was my first
story really what I wanted to do I
didn't know what the character was going
to be like I was still kind of half
merry in my head because I was playing
partly just because I was calling for a
month and still but now looking back on
it I think that's the complete anomaly
in my costumes and the minute I got
about a third of the way into that story
I thought no there this is hopeless I
can't do this anyway so then I did go to
people like June Hudson who was
wonderfully amenable June would come to
me and say I sort of see you in this
kind of Emma Peel type cat suit and I'd
say oh do you I see myself in school
uniform and she always said okay fine
that's a good idea and we'd change and
we'd we'd adapt something quirky and do
I just wanted to wear the sorts of
things I thought would amuse children
and I thought school uniform would amuse
poor little girls that had to wear
school uniform so yes I had a lot of
input in the sorts of things also I was
fearfully practical I mean I was not
bloody well going to wear high-heeled
boots that I couldn't move about in
horrible quarries in Dorset or somewhere
I was going to wear nice flat squishy
shoes that I could run in you know try
and keep up with Tom so that was part of
it I thought I don't know if people are
looking at my feet then the performance
can't be worth watching so I'm not going
to wear high heels and that's that
so yeah I have a lot of say now as you
mentioned earlier there's going to be
more Big Finish audio with Tom what kind
of things we look forward to with that
well novelty I've never done anything
with Tom Lee for a great many years
since I left the program in 1980
so far it's very nice to review to do a
reprise of that those two characters
working together I've done quite a lot
of Big Finish but I think these are very
different inevitably because I'm doing
them with Tom after all this time which
I hope I don't know and we'll wait and
see what's it been like getting into
that character but in Gaudio terms and
joining back with Tom but just with the
voice as it were I love doing audio
stuff I don't find it it's so easy to
fall back into being the character a
much of the Big Finish stuff I've done
I've moved on as a character and I'm
president of Gallifrey and everything's
a bit different you know one of the
things I love is being able to work with
people I would never normally have
worked with like I've done a lot with
Louise Jameson my Louise and I get on
very well we're incredibly different but
we work together very very well and we
we're great friends and that's been a
real joy working with Louise whom I'd
only ever met before things like this at
conventions you know and never thought
that I'd work with so from that point of
view it's been good I love audio you can
do so much with your voice and it's a
fantastic team and we record in the most
wonderful studios Toby who's the sort of
chief engineer there who runs them makes
lunches that we would all sign up to
these audios just to have Toby's lunches
and I'm sure you've been told that
before by other people they are
spectacular and it's a tiny little
studio but it's so well run and he's so
clever and we all just have a wonderful
time
they're very professionally done very
hard work and very exciting and just
lovely I love them I'm glad to hear
there is enjoyable to make if they are
to listen to the audio ones have really
enjoyed even even in the very good old
days of doing the visual stuff which
were tough because you know we had so
little time the schedule was so crazy
but they were never not fun we always
had a good time on them I think and the
audio ones are more relaxed because
audio just is I mean of course we're in
the 50th year now aren't we the
anniversary what would you like to see
happen in the 50th anniversary special
and what do you think of Paul McGann
reappearing as the doctor in the middie
episode well I think it's lovely that
Paul's reappearing I did shudder with
Paul for audio and he I think he's an
absolutely wonderful actor and a lovely
guy so that's great I mean I'm delighted
and I asked me what I'd like to see
happen I wouldn't have thought of that
and that's such a good thing to have
done that they can really please I don't
know really what I one waits to see him
be surprised like the rest of the world
what do you think about the next doctor
Peter Capaldi what do you think he'll
bring to the role well I hope possibly
not the language he had in the thick of
it I think he is spectacularly clever
casting I think he's an utterly
wonderful actor I can't imagine a more
interesting person to play Doctor Who
nah
I can't wait to see it I think he's just
I thought he was so brilliant in the
thick of it utterly utterly brilliant
it'll be just fascinating to see what he
does bring to it and what we look
forward to hearing or seeing from you
next I don't know I hope I'll have
another exhibition soon I do a lot of
work with I draw with a sewing machine
so I've just had three exhibitions at
the National Theatre I'm plotting
another one but possibly in another
country at the moment so that'll be the
next were key type thing but more
immediate will be those big finishes
very much look forward to that same
thing is talking to us today thank you
so much
you